[Music]
hi there very good evening to you
watching the Press preview a first look
at what's on the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers as they arrive or
let's see what's making the headlines
with the journalists and broadcaster
Jenny cleeman and the telegraph's
associate editor for politics so
Christopher hope as you can see they are
standing by evening to you both thank
you for joining us tonight they'll be
with us from now until midnight this
evening let's see what's on some of
those front pages first though starting
with the I newspaper it reflects on
events in turkey and Syria with the
headline race to find Quake survivors
the times also leads on the aftermath of
the Quakes their headline life and death
under the ruins the guardian reports on
the minimum 30-year prison centers given
to the former metropolitan police
officer and confessed rapist David
Carrick the Metro quotes the Home
Secretary swella bravman describing
Carrick as being a scar on our police
and the telegraph tomorrow says they're
already calls to review carrick's
sentence for being too lenient their
financial times has word of today's mini
cabinet reshuffle and with it the
breakup of the department for business
into smaller Ministries devoted to
energy and also to science while the
Daily Mirror leads on the reaction to
oil giant BP's record profits according
to the Daily Mail tomorrow the Church of
England May soon debate whether to stop
referring to God as he the son has word
of a Revival of the classic sitcom
Faulty Towers with a John Cleese
starring alongside his real-life
daughter and on that theme the Star
newspaper tomorrow claims that 42 of
people surveyed cannot remember the last
time that they laughed
and a reminder for either by scaling the
QR code that you'll see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch it with us
let's reintroduce our guest tonight
Jenny kleeman and Christopher hope are
with us evening to you both thank you so
much for staying out way past your
bedtimes I am sure
um and let's start with the the
telegraph Jenny to you first and uh a a
picture of Hope perhaps amongst the
devastation that we are seeing on our TV
screens in Syria and turkey a young
newborn baby found underneath the rubble
in Turkey tell us more
the newspapers have a different job when
it comes to telling this story to news
channels like yourself
couple images that that sum up the mood
of the day and there are a couple of
really striking Stills as opposed to
video image Stills that that are on the
papers today this little girl is a
symbol of of Joy but also great sadness
um she was born as the telegraph says
beneath the rubble now she is a sole
survivor because she has been born an
orphan her mother has died her brothers
and sisters have died her parents have
died she was found in the rubble with
her umbilical Accord still attached
she was saved by The Rescuers there's
some extraordinary video footage in fact
and there's a still from from some of
that video
and in the piece there of of the baby
coming out of the rubble and what a
Survivor this little girl is uh not just
surviving an earthquake but these
incredibly bitter temperatures uh and
according to the telegraph she's getting
better by the hour I mean we need good
stories positive stories reasons to feel
hopeful but as Mark Austin was saying
people are not being pulled out of the
rubble alive as much as they they were
only a few hours ago
um you know we are now looking at a
massive catastrophe over 7 000 dead
state of emergency announced in 10
provinces uh in Turkey this little girl
was pulled out of the rubble
um in Syria and things are even more
difficult in Syria uh because of course
it's the Northwest that's affected
that's the part of the country uh that
has been under siege for so many years
uh in the Civil War roads have been
disrupted you know it really is very
desperate times in that part of the
world desperate indeed uh Jenny talk to
strike taking photos Christopher I don't
think you're going to find one more
striking than on the front page of the
Ft tomorrow of course other newspapers
use as well I mean it really is just
heartbreaking isn't it a man holding the
hand of his 15 year old girl who sadly
has died
but that's right life and death in in in
Syria there that that image for almost a
doll that actually newborn baby being
carried out from the rubble on our front
page the Telegraph and then they're
supporting the sad story of message
Hansa holding the hand of his 15 year
old uh dead daughter in irmac I mean I
think this uh it's shocking you see
around him there in that photograph all
parts of his presumably his house or his
home
um just crushed there as all these
clouds fell down
um it's it's so sad I mean it is tragic
what what can you say apart from the
fact that uh on these stories that Jenny
says papers tell a story many through
pictures with some eyewitness and they
try and zero in on stories which might
try and bring the story alive for
readers and here's an example in the Ft
yes a picture really does paint a
thousand words I mean there is little
more to add read to those photos and of
course we know now that uh more Aid is
on the way International Teams are
arriving so hopefully we will have more
more stories or good news stories coming
out but they are precious few and far
between as Mark Austin was telling us
just a short time ago as he is live of
course in Turkey right now
um Jenny let's move on shall we because
lots and lots of other stories making
the headlines onto the front page of a
guardian another and really enormous
story for us David Carrick of course
that's the former metropolitan police
officer disgraced and convicted rapist
um monstrous rapist x-met officer jail
for life after years of attack that's
how the gardener going of it tomorrow
tomorrow morning what do you make of
their coverage
36 life sentences minimum of 30 years
the guardian are focusing on uh the
judge's comments they're a fantastic
sentencing comments by the judge
actually I found uh that he believed his
position in the Met made him Untouchable
he was not just any copper not just any
policeman he was entrusted to God
Parliament and diplomatic sites uh you
know any multiple Gravely
it's crimes but this is just
particularly uh heinous because he used
his his role to gain
stop them from
to power and in many ways his victims
have been doubly victimized they were
made to feel that there was no
Justice and they were made to feel that
that you know they were afraid of of uh
what what might happen if they reported
him they felt that no justice was due to
him I mean I think this sentence is is
apt I mean we'll go on to discuss
whether or not it's long enough because
of course the telegraph is focusing on
that there were so many warning signs
here so many opportunities to stop this
man the fact that he was only uh he only
lost his job when he pled guilty uh a
month ago uh there are likely to be of
of these kinds of crimes and obviously
Carrick uh was uh the reports against
him were made in the Fallout after the
investigation over Sarah everard's
murder the women who came forward are
incredibly Brave incredibly Brave it's
hard enough uh to uh secure a rape
conviction when the person you're
accusing is not a police officer so um
this is all testimony to their
incredible bravery it's a good sentence
far too late I hope he has fun uh during
his 30 years in prison because I know
it's not a very good place for police
officers to go Christopher many
newspapers also leading with Carrick
let's have a look at how the the Metro
have led with it a scar on our police of
course that's a quote from the Home
Secretary uh swella bravaman what do you
make of their coverage
well exactly I think that Metro is a
paper read and seen by commuters and by
people traveling I think they always do
really do really well I think with these
these shocking uh photographs this
picture of this uh this policeman
staring out their Carrick staring out at
the reader um I think it's really I mean
it's it's appalling I mean and it's not
not the biggest not the Saturday won't
be the uh the uh end of these kind of
stories as we know uh when um Carrie
played guilty last month we found out
that they met police investigating more
than a thousand uh sexual domestic abuse
claims involving 800 officers we don't
know how any of those investigations
might end up where they're going
um this could be one fears the tip of
the iceberg some art Rowley the new met
police chief says we have failed that
was last month he's sorry uh he the he's
this man should never be a police
officer but he was and why that is I
don't know and if these cases still
start to emerge at a rate of knots it
could be a real a real crisis approach
in the police that isn't if it's not one
one already already in our front page at
the telegraph we're saying that the
Attorney General May well review it and
in fact sorry has started with your
review whether this this uh 36 uh this
term for 30-year term
um uh 36 life sentences is enough it
should be out when he's 78 uh we draw
attention to other cases of prolific
rapists reinards sanaga Joseph McCann
have their minimum tariffs increase from
30 to 40 years on under the injury
lydian sentence scheme uh it may be that
that's what happens to this individual
yeah um let Jenny let's bring you back
in and uh just carry on from what Chris
was saying look at the front page of the
day Telegraph uh and and their angle as
you said Christopher uh they go with the
the news that the Attorney General's
already been inundated with complaints
that his sentence of 30 plus years is
too lenient I think they're wanting a
whole life sentence certainly some
people are and um and and within the
copy um Jenny they say it comes as the
metisbrace for more police to face
serious criminal charges after a review
was launched of allegations of sex
offenses and domestic abuse against
officers so this could just be the
beginning and what a nightmare for the
Met police
yes but the Met police has had a problem
with its culture uh for a very long time
now we know that Dane crested dick
presided over a met police that uh was
uh where racist banter was fine
homophobic banter was fine where there
was a lot of domestic abuse among uh
serving male police officers
um I think the whole issue with the
sentence is interesting when you have
prolific rapists like Raynard singer
serving uh 40 years you you have to
think whether or not uh this is
comparable
um and I think it would it would be
important to show that there is a kind
of parity between the the level of
seriousness of the crimes but of course
we know when we're looking about the
absolute crisis and rape conviction in
this country and how badly we do uh when
it comes to Prosecuting rape that
actually what's more important is to
make sure that we can get people
convicted at all let alone how long they
serve what do you think this means for
the Metropolitan Police and what what do
they need to do Christopher to rebuild
trust I mean you mentioned London
commuters there and women in particular
living in the capital
I think Mark Rowley as I said earlier
gets it he they want to be completely
open I mean they've got to open about
the investigation and they're going to
really they are they're checking records
of a lot of police at the moment to find
out if any other uh appalling the evil
people like this
that there's been a seriously been a
major problem here with vetting
um when issues emerge why are some
overlooked why aren't they investigating
why aren't why aren't police sir
policemen found who who commit these
crimes a means he thrown out what what
why is there a pause why is delay
there's a whole
um area of public confidence I think
unaddressed at the moment and that's why
I think this will be the first major
test of Mark Rally's time as the Met
police chief Jenny you're nodding do you
want to have a comment on that
yeah I mean I would say perhaps the
biggest problem that Crescent had or the
biggest criticism you could make of her
is she was very much a Copper's copper
and she always um
she was working with and and that was
the problem is that she kind of she was
Defensive
um first and I think maybe we just have
to really hope that that attitude has
changed with the new met commissioner
okay a lot of news coming out of
Westminster let's see how the financial
times have covered it today we've had a
a cabinet mini reshuffle and also a bit
of a white hole reshuffle as well the
financial times describing it as soon as
breaking up business department to shop
and focus on energy and science they go
on to say that he believes this is going
to help um turn Britain into a science
superpower and also um get a big growth
plan underway what do you make of it
Christopher
well I mean it's interesting isn't it
that the only newspaper just to Splash
on this first big reshuffle by which you
see like is the Ft which says yes it
hasn't really set the house light in
Westminster I mean only which is like
could do a reshuffle and actually sack
nobody essentially nobody's lost their
jobs here he's created new jobs and new
departments for people
um and one hopes it works it's not quite
what the base wants what the supporters
want they want some evidence of a plan
maybe towards tax cuts maybe early next
year but this is this is a classic kind
of tsunac idea really of of playing
around with name name tags in Whitehall
trying to work out the best way to get
the best growth but will this be enough
there's a left to go out tonight from
Greg hands who's the new chair in the
Tory party in the subject uh bar it says
18 and that means 18 months to deliver
for this government I.E election is
going to be September October next year
can the changes which sunax push through
today unexpectedly but deliver that
growth within 18 months so I'm not so
sure and that's the concern for a lot of
people who want the tourists to try and
fight labor properly and not be so far
behind the polls yeah the talking of the
polls the ft like that the government is
seeking to make up for a 20-point lag in
the polls right now and and then also
highlight the fact that the down history
have declined to say how much this
overhaul could cost Jenny
uh yeah I mean the the first line of
this ft coverage is really interesting
I'm going to read it Rishi sunak has has
sought to galvanized his government's
growth plan by breaking up its business
department
Financial Times I mean this is the whole
point he's signaling his priorities
which is for for Rishi Rishi sunak uh
growth means uh Science and Technology
it means energy security maybe you could
see this whole Net Zero thing as a a
repost to those disappointed with his uh
stance to uh uh cop last year in charmel
Sheikh and his dithering over it but you
know
a lot of um app
roaching emails civil servants changing
offices and for what I mean it's just
moving the furniture around a bit and
tinkering around the edges and it
doesn't solve problems with the NHS or
with Dominic Robb or with strikes so
this looks a bit like window dressing to
me uh rather than a prime minister who
feels he's powerful